xuckerberg has finally given up on the
metaverse to most of you this probably
isn't that surprising within just the
past two years the metaverse has lost
meta 24 billion dollars but despite the
Hefty losses it seemed like Zuckerberg
was willing to push forward it no matter
what but it seems like there was one
factor that was big enough to scare him
away from the metaverse shareholders
Zuckerberg technically has over 50
voting control at meta but that doesn't
mean that he can do whatever he wants
and this stock will perform well between
late 2021 and the late 2022 Mata stock
plummeted an eye-watering 77 percent
this translates to a market cap loss of
wait for it 808 billion dollars